what is going on everybody welcome to
part 8 of our intermediate Python
programming tutorial series in this
tutorial what we're going to be talking
about is zip the zip file takes elements
from multiple iterables and aggregates
them into one where we basically share
the index value let's say so I think
it's easier to understand if we just
show it really quickly so we're going to
work with the following data as soon as
I found my mouse say X is equal to 1 2 3
& 4
I can't remember I think I've covered it
already but in according to Pepe we make
a list like this it's comma space just
no spaces in the parameters of a
function for example but it's really
tempting for me personally to do things
like this instead so sorry if I do that
but in theory Pepe it should be like
this so we're going to have some simple
some simple lists you don't have to make
them exactly as I do just have some
lists I'm just here showing that we can
bring together lists of different types
data from lists of different types okay
so first let's go ahead and combine x
and y so what we can say is for a be in
zip X Y print a B so the intuition here
what's supposed to happen is it's going
to tie together x and y so we should see
1 7 2 6 3 2 and 4 1 let's see what we
get
sure enough one seven two six or two for
one as expected so we can also do
multiple elements so we can say a B C
and zip X Y Z and of course we get the
exact same thing now what if we just
said what if instead we just said we
wanted to two cuz in here we're
basically iterating over the result of
zip X Y Z so you might be thinking okay
zip X Y Z must equal a list of either
tuples
or lists of these pairs or triplets I
suppose anyway you might think that
that's what's happening but it's not so
let's just go ahead and look at what is
print zip X Y Z it is a zip object now
as if as if object can be iterated over
so of course we can say for I in zip X Y
Z print I and we see it is tuples of the
values okay
so that makes sense another thing that
we could do say you didn't want to just
iterate over them we actually can
convert a zip to a list so actually I'll
just convert this one up here you can
just say I want this now to be a list of
the zip and we can print that out and
that works as well also interestingly it
won't work with three values but with
two values you can say rather than lists
we can convert it to a dict and now you
have dictionary where the key is that
first value and the value is the second
value so we can also obviously combine
zip with list comprehensions so we can
do things like print ABC or ABC in
the XYZ not to not too surprising
nothing to write home about here but I
do want to point out a potential issue
that if you're commonly using this code
and then you might revert back to a for
loop and you're comparing the two and
you're like what is happening because
the for loop is doing something
different
I'll show you what can happen so
sometimes it might be tempting to take
this line and instead maybe we're going
to we could write this we could print
print X Y and we'll just do X Y for X Y
in zip X Y this seems seems good right
so we'll run that and we get what we
expected and then later on if we decided
we wanted to print X is X what we
expected X to be 1 2 3 4
yep that is what we thought X was going
to be because we know that these are
temp temporary variables right in a for
loop but hmm is that the case
so what have we said for a B or print a
B for a B in zip X Y and then we print a
after that so there's these variables
okay we get a is not defined but what if
we did the same list comprehension just
in a typical for loop well we would say
for a B in zip X Y print a B same thing
I'm just going to comment this out but
it's the same it's going to produce the
same output anyway but see what happens
on the print a huh looks like that a was
stored what's more is instead of before
when we when we said in the list
comprehension example for XY or print X
Y for X Y in zip X Y we recognize that
these were just temporary values they
weren't actually being stored but
the for-loop they are stored so when you
say print or 4xy and zip XY this will
work it's going to work it's going to be
fine no one's going to lose their shirt
but when we go to print X afterwards let
me just comment this out it's it's
overwritten XY so you might find
yourself in a scenario where you're not
using those comprehension you're writing
a simple for loop and because you've
gotten away with this in list
comprehension you think you're going to
get away with it here but you don't and
then you decide that you're going to
iterate again like for X or for I in X
or something like this you're going to
continue using that X variable and it's
just not going to work so just remember
that in list comprehension these values
aren't going to overwrite your original
variables and in fact they're uneven
stored after the loop but or after the
full iteration is complete but in
regular for loop that value is stored
and it's going to overwrite your old old
variables so if you get in the habit of
just using the same variable names as
you're iterating over it it's probably a
bad idea because you're going to you
might find yourself in a situation like
this so anyways that's zip if you have
any questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to little below otherwise I
will see you in the next tutorial